to someone who's never taken ayahuasca
how would you describe the experience
oh that's a really good question i would
describe it
as could be literally nothing and you
have to be prepared for that and not get
frustrated if it's literally nothing
and then it could be literally within
minutes of having consumed it the most
intense
most visionary fastest moving
outside of the box out of body
experience that you could possibly ever
imagine and you have to be prepared for
that as well
when people ask you what you do what's
your answer
i tell them i do a lot of different
things uh
you know mostly i just say that uh i try
to help people
uh advise people guide people um
but really i'm an entrepreneur and an
inventor
and uh leader for humanitarianism and
really the good of all
we focus our work really around
positivity and unconditional love for
humanity uh we believe in a core
fundamental principle that everyone is a
unique
and inspired miracle created by the
universe itself in a
truly scientifically biological way and
also in not explainable mystical
extraordinary consciousness way and that
uh
those are converged in in us ourselves
and so
uh through the different kinds of
projects that i work on the goal is
always to have a positive outreach
and ultimate support i'm well known for
working
in uh you know the space of amazonian
shamanism
and amazonian plant medicine as well as
the different consciousness arts
and so um i'm most noted for that but
i'm also very interested in
technology and new kinds of technology
blockchain technology
and cutting-edge tech projects and
things like that so
they're sort of the ancestral and what's
coming into the future and i really
love the idea of a much larger timeline
i like to think of things
you know millions and millions of years
ago and the millions of years to
comments
so i kind of find myself in the middle
of that and uh trying to make his most
positive
positive impact as we can while we're
here alive yeah you're crossing all of
the streams there right
going from the amazonian traditional
shamanic medicine right up to blockchain
yeah but i think what people don't
understand is that shamans were the
original technology
like a lot of people don't know that the
buffalo drum you know just the circular
buffalo drum
and just played it 210 beats per minute
creates theta binaural beats
so shaman 60 000 years ago we're
creating theta binaural beats like
you'll now find on youtube
and they were sitting around just like
learning how to trans that's tech
it's not very like it's not like crazy
complex
chips and silicon chip tech it's pretty
simple tech but
it was doing the same thing to
consciousness in the brain and then i
think well the shamans were there as
like original scientists they were
eating the berries that no one else
would eat and some of them died
and then some of them ate them and
didn't die and had this huge
mind-opening experience and went whoa
language and you know we can communicate
with so much more so they were sort of
like
you know deep in tech before i think uh
you know whatever has happened in the
last couple thousand years of
civilization
kind of made shamanism go underground
and institutions become really really
more powerful than
tribes but the shamans have always been
involved in
ultimately their own kinds of technology
and i always thought of amazonia and
plant shamanism
as a kind of technology they uh they had
this
the shamans had this amazing means
of not only communicating with the
plants which is what a lot of our
technology recently has been about it's
about tech you know
these communicative evolutions they had
the ability to directly communicate with
plants which
you know growing up you you heard of
some people who hug trees and that was
kind of weird or
you heard us of people that like in
their garden talk to their plants and
the
plants grew better and stuff but these
guys literally would say they were
talking to the plants so i was like okay
as an anthropologist that was like
mind-blowing like what do you mean
you're talking to the plant and the
plant can talk back you know so that to
me seemed like a communicative
technology
and then they could also heal people
with that which to me seemed like an
even
more amazing understanding of medicine
and uh in my early 20s i was enthralled
with
uh this idea that there were people who
still were alive who had ancient
knowledge
and that they knew of medicines that
were intermixed with mysticism
and somehow that knowledge had been
passed down through thousands of years
without being corrupted
by the expansion of western civilization
and still somehow could possibly exist
in the world like
i was enthralled with that idea and so
uh i met some people in the in deep in
the amazon forest who represented these
technologies and so
i thought it's kind of natural that uh
you know they kind of go hand in hand
but most people don't think of it
that way no not at all what is the
current
state of the shaman and tribe
world at the moment you know when i
think about that and most people as well
i'm going to presume
we think of indigenous prehistoric times
you know before we have the 21st century
and all of the
accoutrements that have come along with
it what's the current setup are there
still many shamans around are there many
tribes around that are doing this sort
of practice
oh yeah the all the tribes have shamans
and the practices have continued uh
you know i think that people in general
whether western or indigenous have found
that uh the just mass production of
western industrialization makes a whole
bunch of really interesting products and
things that they like to have
so you see a lot of indigenous people
with ear buds and stuff
you know so you know it's that you know
they wear western clothes on sometimes
because it's just easier than the other
kind of clothes you know etc you see
that but it hasn't changed very much
inside the mind
of the the indigenous people in terms of
their their mysticism and their belief
systems
their uh you know their deep core
traditions have uh persevered
and their understanding of medicine and
shamanism so
all the tribes have shamans and then
every town has different kinds of
spiritual practitioners all along the
amazon river basin so
literally thousands upon thousands upon
thousands of practitioners
how would you define the culture
or you you mentioned about kind of the
internal spiritual
uh thread how would you define that
i think the fundamental uh just
difference is that
there's there isn't a separation between
life and nature
whereas it seems like in the western
mindset there's been a really clear
separation
of what is this urban suburbia and then
what is nature
and nature has been sort of relegated to
national parks and things like that and
people think they go out to nature
and the indigenous people live in nature
so their home is made of nature
and nature is literally outside and they
get their food from nature
and so they're part and parcel with
nature and they live in balance with
that nature and
in a relative state of harmony with that
nature
uh i wouldn't say it's totally
harmonious because some aspects of it
can be rather scary you know when you
live in a place where you realize you
still are
part of the food chain so if you know
that you live in a place where there are
animals that can eat you it kind of
changes your mindset a little bit you
know
but other than that um that's i think
really the the
the big difference is that they just
haven't separated from nature
and that they believe nature is alive
and uh
they roughly translate the term spirit
to that
although i think it has a vast
difference in meaning to that of western
culture
i think with when they're talking about
spirit they're talking about life force
which is a scientifically measurable
concept and understanding
they say that tree has spirit and they
mean that tree's alive
and they say that jaguar has spirit that
jaguar is alive
you have spirit you're alive they're not
um
they're not creating some cartoonish
imagery in their mind or some ghost
story or something like that i think
it's actually much more grounded in what
we would think of as like
energetic physics than uh the way
westerners typically treat it
it's just sort of like there's a big
mystery out there and it's this
forest and the forest is literally
filled with that mystery
and uh if you live out there far enough
away from western civilization long
enough you will meet that mystery
and uh the forest you will realize is
alive and is listening
in many different ways and that is quite
a wild experience to live
i bet it is it's interesting to think
about
the distinction you made there to do
with nature and i'm right in saying that
jungles are the most biodiverse places
on the planet right like the highest
um correct volume of species of all
animals the biggest diversity you're
going to get is going to be in that so
it doesn't really sound that surprising
that the people who live in that
environment
would feel so much more immersed so much
more at one with nature and nature to be
such a larger part of their life and
you're totally correct
the you know there's tons millions and
millions of people
some of whom will be listening who for
whom that tree
at the corner of the street is the like
end point of nature that they're going
to get to see perhaps for this week
they get in the car drive to work office
block paved street
gray skies etc etc um yeah it doesn't
surprise me that we have different modes
of thinking when the environments
that have spawned that thinking are so
disparate
yeah and i completely agree with that
that idea you know
the western concepts of of nature are
just
you know they're just different in that
sense and when you live
in a place where you're hearing nature
literally all the time
at night the amazon is alive and it is
loud
it is symphonic is it really you're
hearing oh yeah i mean it is
literally symphonic you hear uh
literally tens of thousands of species
of animals making different kinds of
sounds
collectively and when you get into the
visionary ceremonies one of the most
amazing things that can happen
is that the the shaman actually know how
to sync with the nature
and get the nature to start to play with
them like a big band
so you'll have a shaman there with just
a rattle and i'm not kidding all of a
sudden the cicadas will take on
syncopated rhythms
the owls will start to hoot right at the
right time the frogs will croak right
like
like it as part and parcel of what's
going on that the shaman just looks at
you like why you don't know what's going
on
right kind of like totally normal like
it's been completely normalized for them
and westerners minds are just going like
you know like like
a brain splatter everywhere about that
you know it's like such a funny
funny thing to see but it's just so true
so when you live in that place where
nature is just part of literally
everything that you're doing
uh not a store right it's not a store
that's part of everything that you're
doing it's nature that's part of
everything that you're doing
uh it's really easy to experience it
that way in its diversity and in its
understanding of life and and it has so
much energy
uh you know in the sense of just that
much sound
you know i think of like what a rock
concert is and how or like an edm
festival and how much
energy is going to making that sound and
i think about the forest and i think
it's making more
sound it's making more energy than that
huge
you know edm festival all the time just
by itself that is what they call
the force of nature or the force of
spirit and it's uh
it's truly palpable when you're there
and you're in it you know you feel it
you hear it you experience it
i wonder what it would be like for some
of the
people who are indigenous to that
environment to come and live in the
silence
the relative silence of sort of lower
suburban
western society if they're used to such
noise levels and then you were to bring
them into
a quiet street in the in the uk or in
midwest of the us or something like that
i i wonder what they would make of that
i think it'd be scary
i think it'd be the flip opposite of
what happens when you take somebody else
down there i think it literally would be
scary for them
uh i do know a number of people who've
moved from the jungle
out to other areas and then it's often
that they come back and they just don't
relate like the culture shock is so
great they're just like nah
i think i'm gonna go back to that yeah i
want the symphony of different insects
if that's all right please
exactly exactly yeah so we've talked
absolutely the big difference
we've spoken about the plant medicine
we've danced around it so far
take us through what we need to know
about it what is it
uh it's kind of it's diverse it's
unbelievably diverse it's found all
around the world there's all different
kinds of plants that
have a psychoactive capacity associated
with them
some of them that are unbelievably mild
uh most people interact with these
plants on a daily basis in the form of
some kind of tea or coffee
you know it's it's that's what it is
it's a plant that has
an ability to affect the psychological
state or the state of consciousness that
you're in
and then there are some that are just
unbelievably extreme
and so the the panorama that you get is
just
you know super vast and then you get all
the way to the point of
what are considered sort of the master
teacher plants and they're the ones that
most people know about such as like
ayahuasca san pedro watchuma
peyote eboga
toy which is kind of brugmans here at
datura some of them
are safer some of them are unbelievably
dangerous you know there's all different
kinds of
mushrooms and things that people have
heard about that create these
psychedelic states or visionary states
and um you know i think people around
the world have
been utilizing these kinds of plants
since the origin of time i think it's
part of
the natural evolution which is why the
brain has receptors for these chemicals
in them in
its own right otherwise there would be
no way to have an experience with these
plants
but the plants have certain kinds of
compounds in them that when
in the brain and when being metabolized
by the body creates a very altered state
of consciousness
and then uh people you know often refer
to that as like tripping
you know or something like that but
that's very uh unguided and undirected
and then you get all the way to like
amazonian plant medicine
where there are people who've actually
learned how to guide and direct
the states of consciousness that people
go through in those
ceremonies when they have ingested those
kinds of plants
really for the purpose of healing or for
the purpose of exploration and
transformation
so it's for healing or learning and the
kinds of healing
has been now documented over the last 20
30 years as being unbelievably vast and
really important
from depression to anxiety disorders
ptsd
all different kinds of traumatic events
from the past that people have healed
from as benign as just the difficulties
of growing up all the way to truly
incurable uh diagnosed you know
by psychologists and psychiatrist
illnesses that these plant medicines
have been able to ultimately treat
and uh in the indigenous sense there's a
person who's called a shaman
or a medical vegetalista which means
doctor of plants
and they know how to guide that
experience and they do so through sound
and through the altered state of
consciousness that they've learned how
to be a part of so it's a slightly
different kind of medicine than your
experience from a western doctor
who sort of gives you a prescription and
says here go take these pills
in this case the doctor takes the
medicine with you
so you guys sit down together and you
you both uh tip back the cup of tea or
whatever it is that you guys are using
to
to do this kind of healing ceremony and
then you go into an altered state of
consciousness that has a real purpose
and the purpose of the altered state of
consciousness is to ultimately take you
into a personal recognition that you
have transcended
the illness you have transcended
whatever it is that was afflicting you
and actually now has created a state of
healing and on the other side of that
journey
you come out of it transformed and or
healed and you're trained
as one of these plant doctors yeah i
started my training in my early 20s i
was 23 years old when i started training
and now i'm 42 so i've been practicing
for the last 19 years
uh it's been a wild ride i have to say
but it has yeah
yeah it wasn't what i was thinking when
i was growing up
in american suburbia that this would
ultimately sort of be my destiny
but i i feel truly blessed to have been
um invited into an uh indigenous lineage
and ultimately given the opportunity to
go through apprenticeship
and to learn what these medicines are
and can do
like i said i was really drawn and
really wished that there could be
something more
to this idea of mysticism and uh
knowledge
and i was able to find it in the amazon
through these kinds of plant medicine
experiences and then ultimately
help impart that to really thousands of
people from around the world so i
created a center
called blue morpho and uh blue morph was
one of the first
centers in the world dedicated to
amazonian shamanism and amazonian plant
medicine
in a traditional indigenous way and
we became globally recognized after a
number of people were healed from what
were considered incurable illnesses
and lots of publications happened about
us in the
mid early 2000s and then
from there people came from all over the
world and they got to be introduced to
this kind of
medicine and then also have the
experiences of the ceremonies with us
and it's been a
incredible joy really to be able to work
with people from all over the world
we've had people from over 120 countries
visit us
and uh you know that was something that
i never thought would happen when
we first started out and i think really
the community that's formed
is uh the most impactful part of it out
of all of it for me
that people really did receive a
tremendous amount of benefit from their
experiences with us
in the vast majority and that uh
tremendously incredible relationships
were formed through that work
i know that you've gone online you guys
like everyone this year has had to
pivot even the plant medicine isn't uh
free from the effects of a pandemic
sadly but um where are you based when
you're usually in person where are you
guys based
uh typically in person we're based in
the amazon out of the city of iquitos in
northeastern part of peru
but now we have gone online uh we've
been online though interestingly enough
since 2014.
so we we beat them the curve to the
pandemics
already interested we're covered yeah we
were interested in streaming
and uh we had our own streaming channels
before youtube and facebook had
live streaming as part of their features
so we were really interested in tech i
got interested in tech
uh from the side of really being asked
questions by a whole bunch of tech
people that were coming down to our
lodge so people would come down and
spend
anywhere from a week to nine days with
us and many of them came from the tech
sector and so i would ask them what they
would do they would ask me what i would
do and we'd have these incredibly
in-depth conversations about technology
and i found it fascinating and so when
streaming came around i thought it was a
really interesting idea about how to be
able to share these practices
um where you could really reach out to
people instead of them having to come to
you
you know it was quite a quite a
commitment and a trek to come to
our part of the amazon to be able to
experience this in its native setting
and there were also lots of practices
that weren't specifically dedicated to
psychoactive plants that could also be
shared
that had tremendous value and those
could be shared all over the world there
was no question of legality around the
plants that were being used etc
and so i was really interested in being
able to share that through
technology and through streaming so
we've been streaming since 2014
and we made this pivot to really put the
entirety of our work online
during the time of covid the shutdown
has been uh impressive
yeah at least i bet so you've said that
you've done
uh 19 years of this particular practice
have you got any idea
how many ayahuasca and plant medicine
ceremonies you yourself have done
uh yes and no i it has to be sort of an
approximation because i lost track but
well over four thousand
four thousand yeah oh definitely over
four thousand
uh but i i you know you stopped counting
after the first couple thousand
you know so that's insane i was highly
dedicated and highly motivated
i was i really really enjoyed the work
and and by that i mean like literally
professional ceremonies
not just you know sitting by yourself
etc this is with people
where i was facilitating with other
master shamans or
myself facilitating alone but over 4 000
with
you know with other people where we were
performing the healing arts and the
mystic arts together
wow that's insane that's over a 10-year
so over your full career that would be
one every what
three to four days it would be a
ceremony about once every three to four
days
yeah we didn't really practice that way
though i mean it wasn't spaced out like
that we had practice in groups of
ceremonies
so we would often do nine ceremonies in
a row for instance i've participated in
eight ceremonies in the last nine nights
so i facilitated literally eight
ceremonies in the last nine nights
um just four other people that have
contacted us you know looking for
different kinds of healing
through the trinity retreats that we're
doing online we do three ceremonies in a
row
so you know they get kind of bunched
together and then you take a little time
off and then you do more and then you
take time off and training was extensive
you know i
trained for 13 years and uh when i was
training
um we would participate anywhere from
uh nine nights in a row up to
40 nights in a row so you know you'd
pack in a lot of ceremonies in a very
short period of time
and then you'd take a little bit of time
off let things settle
you know sanity and groundedness is
really important through that level of
practice
and so you need to be really really
careful with what you're doing
in terms of that there's a lot of
restrictions there's a lot of
things you do to make sure that you're
you're staying sane and safe during that
kind of
level of training it would be no
different to that of anyone else who's
doing something very extreme
like extreme sports athletes or ultra
thorners etc that are
you know pushing the envelope but
knowing how to do that
and uh and progressing and so that's not
something that you start out as
you know when i started i thought just
surviving one ceremony was a really big
deal
that was like unbelievably big deal but
yeah over the years they they amassed
they amassed a number
you know again that number's around
about 4 000 which is
just terrifying and the thing is as well
within ayahuasca ceremony it's you we're
not just talking about
half an hour in and out here we're
talking about the majority of a day
right
yeah it's really at night time so
evening tonight
and you could kind of just think of it
as
anywhere from three to eight hours so
each ceremony would be relatively uh
within that time frame so the number of
hours is really quite extensive
that you're in that state it's a
dedication you really dedicate to that
that period of time
and it's really sacred it's it's also
very enjoyable too
if if you like it you know like any
other kind of activity if you really
like something
it's easy to spend time in it but it's
not like your 15-minute meditation
you know it really is kind of a bigger
commitment than that and uh
like i said anywhere from three to eight
hours is normal and then there are the
kinds of ceremonies that go much
much longer than that so i have
participated in ceremonies that
literally go on for days
and uh so that's quite another kind of
uh experience in its own right as well
yeah i bet it is can you talk about the
ingredients that you put together to
make
ayahuasca and how those combine to
actually work
sure i always has a tea it's really
basic
um there's really two principal main
ingredients in our part of the amazon
that gets used one is a vine that's
named ayahuasca
and um i don't know that's its name but
it's a vine
you just kind of see it growing there
like many vines in the amazon
the vines kind of tie the whole amazon
together
you'd rarely see a tree without vines
interconnecting it to another tree so
there are just vines all over the place
and many of them
have medicinal properties associated
with them there are vines for diabetes
there are vines for
different kinds of arthritis there are
vines for different kinds of uh
cold you know kind of like your common
cold and flu and stuff like that
and it happens to be ayahuasca and when
you mix ayahuasca with this
leaf called chakruna um it's a relative
of the coffee family it comes
from a kind of bushy tree that grows in
the shade you take the leaf and the vine
and you put it together and you get
ayahuasca
um that combination is incredibly
visionary
incredibly potent and it's a mixture
of a number of in maoi and
which are these inhibitors that inhibit
an enzyme in the stomach that allows
for the digestion and the uptake of
dimethyltryptamine that comes from
the chakruna into the brain otherwise
the stomach would just break it down and
you wouldn't have any experience at all
so the combination of the vine plus the
chicona leaves
allows for the body to absorb by
inhibiting this enzyme in the stomach
and then uh you have a much longer
experience than
what people know of as like a dmt trip
uh that
lasts in like i said anywhere from three
to eight hours sometimes
13 16 hours and the longest i've seen is
a few days but those are in very rare
cases
uh the and usually very specific reasons
of the the person and why they would
have that experience but
most people are in and out within three
to six hours of the experience and those
are the two main ingredients and then
after that the shaman depending on the
kinds of plants they work with
can use a number of different admixtures
and there is really not just
one recipe of ayahuasca so in our
lineage we can use anywhere
from 7 to 14 other plants that can be
added to the ayahuasca as well
and they're just added to give it more
strength not in the sense to make it
more potent
it's actually the opposite it's to make
you stronger
and more capable of handling the
experience
and so those are typically different
kinds of tree barks that we work with
that come from a whole segment of
shamanism that's called palero shamanism
or tree shamanism
and then also from sanango and the san
angeros which is sannongo bay shamanism
the the shamanism in the amazon's broken
down based on the different kinds of
medicinal plants that you're working
with
and what you've trained with and so
there are many specialties and
our lineage we're trained in five
specialties
of different kinds of visionary plants
and so
they kind of all get intercombined into
the ayahuasca that our lineage uses
so that we can then pull from those
different aspects of the practice
to be supportive and helpful in the
ceremony for all the different variety
of reasons you would
you would see in an ayahuasca ceremony
13 years out of 19 years spent training
ish you said yes during that time what
was the majority
of the training trying to cultivate
is it focusing on your ability to
physically construct the right liquid
and understand how to work with the
materials
is it more the astral side where you're
trying to guide the experience
is it the music how was your time split
um the plant side of it is really not so
so focused on the visionary plants
themselves but literally hundreds of
medicinal plants that are in the amazon
and it's just kind of a sad aspect
of what's happened over the years with
this western interest in just ayahuasca
and those experiences
that they've kind of missed the point of
really what is this
biopharmacology of the amazon so from
sort of the botany side of it there's
literally within a couple of hectares of
amazon hundreds of medicinal plants that
have unbelievably
amazing curative properties right but
you
and you learn about them uh not in your
western educated
sort of teacher with a whiteboard or
chalkboard way
teaching you this is the plant that's
the plant on the contrary you go into
transit and division
in the ayahuasca ceremonies and the
shamans chant
the energy and the healing properties of
the other kinds of plants
and then in your vision you see where
they are in the forest
and they teach you about the plants
through the visions themselves which is
a completely other
worldly concept of education which is
hard to even believe that it could be
possible that you could be in trance
that another shaman could be there next
to you chanting and that they could be
through that
imparting the wisdom and knowledge of
lots of different kinds of plants and
its uses
but literally you could be uh in your
vision
you know having the ceremony take place
at night but in your vision it's daytime
you're in the forest you're standing
there with next to the shaman
the shaman is showing you a plant it's
showing you the leaves it's showing you
how to use the leaves
it's showing you how to prepare the
leaves all within the vision itself
within the ceremony and the next day
you could walk out into the forest
literally into that location and find
that plant
and so that's sort of the the nature of
apprenticeship and
you spend most of your time learning
about the plants
through the ceremonies themselves so you
do a process of diets which they call
dieta which just means diets
and that's a time where you drink or
consume
teas or different kinds of elixirs made
out of lots of different kinds of
medicinal plants
most of which like i i say are not
psychoactive most of them
are um just like if you made mint tea
and you're having a cup of mint tea just
simple as that and
uh you learn how to work with the plant
that way through these
these diets you follow extensive
restrictions of behavior
there's sexual abstinence absence from
alcoholic beverages abstinence from
uh spicy foods there's a very limited
diet you're allowed to eat during that
period of time
etc and you go through these dietas and
then during that time you also
participate
in visionary ceremonies depending on the
plants that you're
training with and that you're working
with and that's really how you spend
your time
and so you're you do these diatos the
diet does last
anywhere from six days to nine days to
15 days in some traditions it's a month
long
three months long six months long or
even a year long at a time of training
and it is literally 24 hours a day
you're said to be taught in the
visionary space and in the dream time
and um that's kind of how you spend your
time
in our case uh training for me was spent
between
foraging for food and going to the
agricultural place we lived off of the
land itself
you'd go out in canoes and go fishing
you would
you know collect food and during the day
or you would do other kinds of mending
or building
or the creating of the tools that you
needed it was you know very rudimentary
life where i lived there were very few
inhabitants there were about
uh maybe 50 to 60 people in total and
for miles and miles and miles of jungle
where i lived
and so you spend a lot of time just kind
of
foraging and being part of nature and
interacting with nature and then
the rest of the time is spent in
ceremonies as part of the diet
you mentioned that there's been this
recent influx of
western tourists i suppose wanting to
come and do
i don't know what you call it it's kind
of like a a psycho holiday
psychonaut holiday of one of one kind or
another um
and that perhaps jaded some people's
opinions and also narrowed the focus
that we're aware of certainly i think
ayahuasca is the most
famous of plant medicines but you're
right there's magic mushrooms and lsd
and other psychedelic
uh compounds that we can get natural and
obviously
uh synthesized how important
is it for people to use the ayahuasca
in the traditional sense ceremony guided
music at night in nature as opposed to
in a more transactional i guess
classic western sense you know someone
to order
i'm gonna guess the dark web's got
everything on it i'm gonna guess that
someone in the dark web somewhere
probably sells the ingredients or
perhaps even like a pre-mixed
dry thing and then someone at the house
could do it how important is it
to go through the full ceremony and have
the guidance there with you
uh i would say that the the level of
importance is
the same as going to a trained surgeon
or a completely untrained surgeon
needing a heart transplant
so you need a heart transplant and
you're gonna go to somebody who
literally has never done it before
or you're going to go to a trained
person who is a
you know highly trained specialist and
has done many of those
and knows how to actually do that i
think it's literally
uh that severe so you can akin to it to
a life-and-death situation uh you need
your life saved you want it saved by
somebody who knows what they're doing in
western medicine
if you go down to tribal amazonian
medicine you want somebody
that knows what they're doing and that
has had at least a minimum of five if
not ten hopefully fifteen years of
training and experience as a minimum
yeah i've heard as i'm sure you will
have done in many of the people
listening about
experiences where uh shamans who are
perhaps
less qualified or just more careless i
suppose
have taken groups of western tourists
and i guess not given them the level of
care
that they should have done whilst giving
them the level of drugs that they
perhaps wanted
it's you know it's a very dangerous
thing fact of the matter is especially
with westerners who take all different
other kinds of medications and don't
understand the contraindications
and the intramixes of mixing plants with
other kinds of pharmaceuticals
oh so there's an interaction there as
well
oh absolutely and there's a whole list
of pharmaceuticals that are
contraindicated to
the amazonian medicinal plants and in
the centers that are really uh serious
there's medical screening
before you're allowed to participate in
the ceremonies
and that's just not being upheld by a
lot of different people and it
la it adds to a tremendous amount of
danger associated to the
potentials of what could ultimately
happen but you really should follow a
medical intake form
and the people who are organizing the
experience need to
take it as seriously as running any
other kind of clinic
to understand whether or not you're a
suitable candidate to participate in the
ceremonies themselves
and then you also have to understand the
so not only the interactions with
western pharmaceuticals
you also have to understand your own
sensitivity to other kinds of plants as
well
and often because ayahuasca is mixed
with lots of other kinds of plants
uh ayahuasca can be blamed for things
that have happened that really
are the admixtures that have been added
to ayahuasca
so i know of people who have been
poisoned from tobacco
and they had just so much tobacco as
part of the ritual and ceremony and they
had such a sensitivity to tobacco
that they ended up getting tobacco
poisoning not poisoned from ayahuasca
and they ended up having severe health
consequences not at our center because
luckily we don't use tobacco that way
but uh it just happened to be that way
and or things like brugmansia which is
called took
away our angel trumpet vine is also
unbelievably psychedelic
and incredibly dangerous and people die
from it all over the world
from mistreating that plant and it can
also be used as an admixture in
ayahuasca and then you know because the
name is ayahuasca it gets misunderstood
that there were these other compounds
and other plants that were added to it
that has literally altered what it is
and that the people
that were uh you know taking the plant
they did not
there's no story about what they were
taking beforehand or what their medical
history was or what their family history
is
and if you have a in your family history
a history of dissociative disorders
any kind of mental disorder that's
bipolar any kind of schizophrenia
you should not participate in these
kinds of medicines you should not
participate in these kinds of
psychedelic experiences
especially if you're over the age of 30
there can be a trigger
that can literally kick off out of your
genetics
those uh states of mental illness that
you might not
have experienced before and it's not
talked about and it needs to be taken
very seriously
and as this spreads and people are more
interested in it you're going to hear
more and more stories
of where there has been a mistake that
has been made
and of course what you're going to hear
is the the thunder
around that mistake you're not going to
hear at the same time
the hundreds of thousands of people that
were doing this within a safe way
that were all being healed at the same
time and so the negative gets super
overplayed
but it is unbelievably dangerous and you
have to know whether or not you are
an appropriate candidate to be able to
participate in the ceremony
yeah what is it people are perhaps
when the world reopens thinking i've
considered it for a long time i've done
my research i feel like this is
something that i want to try
how can they assure that the particular
center that they go to or the shaman
that they're working with is legit
because presumably even the ones that
have been around for
a couple of years and don't care that
much about their clients
or their patients i suppose what do you
call them
what are guests guests participants cool
um they don't care that much about their
guests they're still going to say no
don't worry
i am this blah blah blah there's no trip
advisor i'm going to guess for um
for different shamans so what do you do
i fundamentally think you have to do
your homework in your research
uh you need to get online and you need
to look at a variety of centers and you
need to see how long they've been around
and what their track record is
you need to try to find as many comments
as you can in testimonials it's better
if you can find somebody that's been
there and talk with them in person or
chat with them online about it and
experience
you need to look into the shaman's eyes
and see if they look like somebody you
want to vibe with because everyone's
energy is very different
and uh no two shaman are the same and so
i think i'm always looking for someone
who's not trying to you know occult and
be hidden they're willing to be open and
sharing
they're very clear about what their
intention is and what their purpose is
of the work that they're doing
that they have a you know a long history
and track record
of a lot of positive success you'll also
find obviously anybody who has
a very long time doing anything there
are people that like them and don't like
them so you'll see that as well
i think it's also really important to
see how the people treat
the scenarios for the people that
provide criticism against them are they
people that lash out online are they
people that
you know handle themselves in a
respectful honest and caring way
i think all of these things are
important ways of being able to
check out a center and see if they're
viable
see whether or not they do medical
screening very important
do you know does the center do medical
screening and
uh what is their medical screening and
why i think if you have an opportunity
to be able to talk to the people that do
the
booking for them it's really important
that it's not just some online process
but that they're actually somebody to
interact with even if it's just emails
and to be able to ask questions and are
they willing
to provide answers for you and then i
think that regardless of the investment
that you make in it
if you ever arrive at a place and it
doesn't feel right and it doesn't look
right to you you should just leave
it's as simple as that or you should
just not participate in the ceremony
and then you should ask the shaman as
well is it okay if i if i observe the
ceremony
can i actually be here so maybe i go to
a place where there's five ceremonies
and i decide
i want to observe the first one i don't
want to drink i want to get comfortable
with this
experience first just to see what it's
about and how do they treat that
like at art for instance at our center
uh there is no experience
experience that is mandatory and we
allow everybody to be able to observe
without participating in the ingestion
of any of the plants
we don't believe that the ingestion of
the plants is is entirely important to
the nature of the experience of
the healing that somebody can receive
we've had people that come from all
different programs where it's
no longer allowed like 12-step programs
where it's not allowed for them to
participate in psychedelics and things
like that and so they don't drink and
they still have visionary experiences
we tell people that if they're not
feeling comfortable or they're not
feeling up to it to take the night off
it's not about you know night after
night after night participating we offer
the number of ceremonies we offer so
that
people have the maximum opportunity
to receive what they need and for some
people that works really well to
participate in all of the ceremonies a
lot of other people need
many less ceremonies in a week than
what's offered right
one or two or three is enough even if
five or six or seven is offered at the
center
you want to see that the people really
are caring about you
and are interested in your well-being
and and your health and how they are
interacting in that way
and so i think if you do your research
there is a way to be able to get some
clarity on that
and to check inward about that overall
experience
and that it really shouldn't be
offensive in any way to any center any
practitioner
if someone just realizes that they don't
vibe with you and that it's not right
for them
and that even if they need to go
somewhere else instead of you i think
that that's completely fine as well
and um ultimately in that honesty and
clarity i think you can
decide whether or not you want to put
the well-being of your own psyche in the
hands of somebody else
and then you can make that decision
phenomenologically
how would you describe to someone who's
never taken ayahuasca how would you
describe the experience
oh that's a really good question that's
a really good question
i would describe it as
could be literally nothing it could be
literally nothing and you have to be
prepared for that
and not get frustrated if it's literally
nothing
and then it could be literally within
uh minutes of having consumed it
the most intense most
visionary fastest moving
[Music]
outside of the box out of body
experience
that you could possibly ever imagine and
you have to be prepared for that as well
and um my first experience
was literally like 50 to 100 strobe
lights going off at the same time
where each one was a vision that needed
to be dealt with
something recapitulated something purged
something confronted something that was
terrifying me or scaring me
and it lasted hours and hours and hours
and hours and hours until i literally
thought i would die of exhaustion
it was unbelievably intense um
it was by far the most intense
experience of my life up until that
point
uh you can see and hear
and um understand the field of
consciousness and the field of nature in
a way
that makes everything that seems
separate look like it is interwoven
in a lattice of multi-d geometry
of the of the colors made up of the
rainbow and every color you have never
seen before in your life
literally like every single atom of air
is exploding
in an interweb of nature
consciousness and it is all alive and
within it
there is the presence of supernatural
voices
and supernatural beings and supernatural
visions
that could come um as benign as a
whisper
to that of anything from any mythology
you have ever heard of or ever imagined
and things well outside of that in my
first ceremony i
saw 30-foot wingspan hummingbirds that
were having
rainbows exploding out of them a bush
that was next to me had turned into a
wild boar
that was literally telling me what a
terrible job i was doing it criticized
me the entire time about how like i
could not keep it together
um i vomited at least 300 times
at least 300 times in that first
ceremony
and i was literally trapped in a
spiraling
spiral galaxy where the center of it was
a black hole of absolute insanity
taking me to a place 10 billion times
worse than hell
and a huge voice that would sound like
the voice of god
telling me to do the work with me
screaming back i don't understand what
they're talking about
and then just purging and purging and
purging and purging and purging
out all ends with no ability to control
the physical body whatsoever
and then ultimately purging a physical
object the size of a lemon
that felt like hands were squeezing it
out of my stomach
up my esophagus and then out of my mouth
where my mouth unhinged like that of a
snake
and an actual physical ball the size of
a lemon came out of me
and it represented every aspect of
negativity depression
pain and suffering that i had ever
experienced in my life up until that
moment
that whole thing took four and a half
hours and
uh i remember asking the hummingbirds
whose beaks were like three or four
meters long to please not
kill me and spike me i remembered the
bush
telling the bush that it had i finally
agreed it was a boar
and not a bush i definitely realized it
was not a good idea to shape-shift into
a jaguar strip myself naked and run into
the forest that was a bad idea
i realized you have good and bad ideas
some of them you should not follow
i realized there was a purpose to the
purging itself and at the end of it i
was cheered
on by thousands of spirits that i had
actually purged what i was looking for
and uh and i had found my apprenticeship
and that i was going to apprentice
and i remember thinking that that was
the biggest cosmic joke because
there was no way that i would ever
actually be able to learn to have any
sort of
constitution within that space because i
was
dug into the ground the amount of sweat
that had poured out of me had become mud
i was covered in mud from head to toe uh
i i could not move and i remember
getting into my hammock that night uh
thinking to myself if i make it to
morning without soiling the hammock i'll
be really proud of myself like just
please don't spoil the hammock like
i could barely walk um i thought
people who had said it was intense had
kind of overplayed it like oh yeah sure
and then i realized i had underplayed it
like they had underplayed the intensity
it was so intense
and then i learned over the years that
that was not the most intense experience
i've ever had
that was only like a middle grade
experience of total intensity over the
the you know thousand plus ceremonies
that i've been in with with ayahuasca
um and uh and and so you gotta be ready
to
to take a leap of faith literally into
the infinite and eternal astral and be
ready for whatever
and so you want your guides to be really
good and that's my point of
the idea of like the guy giving you the
heart transplant you want your guides to
be really really good
if nothing happens your guide didn't
matter but if that happens you better
have a guide who knows how to handle you
and deal with that and guide you through
that and make sure that you stay
in with the good spirits and the light
spirits and the healing spirits and
energies
and that you know you don't get taken
anywhere that you can't come back from
et cetera you need to have somebody who
knows how to guide that kind of an
experience
it's possible to all of a sudden find
yourself with your eyes open or closed
and
being able to see exactly the same thing
so you're there with your eyes open and
then you close them and then you're
seeing literally the same thing and you
open them again and you close them and
you're not
in the ceremonial house where you
started you are literally somewhere else
and it's not that you're out of body
you're there
as body or you could be disembodied
consciousness just somewhere in outer
space all of a sudden it could be
like literally einsteinian physics
getting sucked into a wormhole
and that wormhole could literally take
you anywhere in infinity
and then you can go from the one black
hole of a spiral galaxy into another
into another into another until you're
like six seven eight dimensions from
where you started
literally filled in worlds of beings
that you have never heard from
of any other kind of mythology you have
never seen anything like this you can't
be like oh
that came from a movie or oh this
experience came from
no this is totally outside the box like
the brain has literally no reference for
it
and you have to be able to keep your
constitution and hang on through that
until you come out the other side and
there is no off button
there is no off switch there's no hey
guys i'd really like to just slow this
down you can't pull the ejector cord
right
there is no eject there's no jack
there's no second parachute
no i mean like literally all the ways
humans have tried to like you know
figure out a way to to give themselves a
second chance when things go wrong it
does not exist in this game
this is a multi-d uh real real-time
real played game i i equated it that
you know every day is the world cup
every day you're in it is the world cup
there's no like warm-up there's no
scrimmage there's no
there's no practice it is the world cups
game you are always
in the championship game every time you
go in there and
no one knows literally even the shamans
what's gonna happen
and so it's not like the shamans have
like a dj has a playlist the shamans
have tools
and they are ready for literally
whatever
and they have thousands and thousands
and thousands of tools that they know
how to use when they're proficient
and they are going to be able to pull
those those tools out like batman using
his utility belt
to have a whole bunch of tools to be
able to take care of whatever could
possibly happen within that room
and then the bigger the ceremony gets
the more exponentially intense it is and
difficult it is to manage so in our
center we work with anywhere from 30 to
40 people at the same time
so if one person is that intense you can
imagine when now you have 30 or 40 going
and that's what it gets unbelievably fun
i mean you got to be up for it but that
is when it gets
unbelievably fun the next day people are
saying like i saw you envision over
there and
this thing came out of you and and we
were here and then
i was like yeah i saw you there too and
it is like a whole world it is like
you are inside the cosmic consciousness
uh
holographic video game for real and the
barriers of consciousness have been
broken down and the barriers of
personality and ego
have been broken down and it is
literally game on and it can be
unbelievably fun or it can be
unbelievably scary and treacherous and
so
you know again that's where you want
your guides to really know what they're
doing have had a lot of experience so
that they're not tossed and thrown by
whatever gets
uh brought forth within that ceremony
and that they're capable of handling
whatever it brings but
you know that's it in a nutshell
man what an unbelievably beautiful
explanation of that
um what insight about
the mind and about consciousness outside
of that realm or what are some of the
biggest realizations and insights that
you've gained from
all of this time that you've spent
but i mean first of all i think the
the biggest one is that you're a miracle
and that we're not taught to think of
ourselves that way but that you're a
miracle
you're an evolutionary miracle and that
you are a biological miracle
and you're a cosmic miracle
and the fact that you're alive it means
you've already won the biggest gift of
all which is just being alive
and most people don't see it that way
the second is that we're not separate in
any kind of way and that we're already
eternal and infinite and what we are is
body
is something that i call being in the
womb of earth you are in the womb of
your mother
and you were born to the world and now
we're all in the earth together
and people like to think that they're on
the earth and we're actually within the
earth
the earth is in through and all around
us and we're made of it
we're literally made of the earth itself
and if you look at the matter of your
body that is the earth
and the earth comes from an unbelievably
huge cloud of stardust and that means
you're made of stardust
so you literally are a stardust
starlight being that lives in outer
space within the density of the earth
created as a miracle and that that
fundamentally is actually true
as hard as is to imagine science can
actually prove that that is a fact
and that the matter of your body is over
12 billion years old
so well we might think of ourselves as
20 30 40 50 60 years old
what makes up your body right now is
over 12 billion years old that stardust
and that that is a fundamental miracle
in its own right and that somehow the
earth has magically organized us
to be able to not only know ourselves
but know each other and be able to speak
common languages that allow us to
interact and that
that that's a miracle and to me it's sad
that we have used that to decide to
fight each other and harm each other
instead of be neutral with each other or
harmonious with each other because we're
all in this together
i always like to say that we need to
start to learn how to get along because
once the universe creates you it doesn't
know how to uncreate you
so you have been created and you will be
created forever and
so we're all in this together literally
forever with all of our ancestors and
all of the species that have gone
and everything that has ever lived and
died is still part of spirit and still
part of the universe
and we will go from the womb of earth
into the womb of the universe itself
which to me is another birth
i've learned that death is not real that
death is an illusion that we're told
about which is the shedding of the body
when consciousness is ready
to be born again not reincarnated to
earth itself there are
sure some people who are being
incarnated to earth but
consciousness is something that is
constantly growing and expanding and
that what we call death is actually a
transition into another state of
consciousness and being
and that it is really about ready to get
born and so we're just super scared
about getting born not super scared of
dying
and we're not sure what we're getting
born into
those are some core some core things
i've learned along the way there's some
fantastic insights
the fascinating unifying thread that i
see
between all of my friends and guests
who've had serious psychedelic
experiences
that haven't been uh purely recreational
should i say even some of the ones who
have just been purely recreational kind
of
have this insight as well but so
few of them live a
reductionist materialist um
have that viewpoint anymore i can know
all that is to be known we can see all
that there is to see etc
um and i've heard you speak to
past modern wisdom guests and good buddy
aubry um about the fact that
anyone who is a skeptic just needs to
try an experience for themselves have
you ever had someone
who has been expressively like overly
skeptical
arrive at one of your particular
retreats and then
seen a 180 polar reverse
flip of the their view of the world
uh literally every single retreat
every retreat there's somebody who comes
unbelievably skeptical
uh this is an experience that if you
haven't had it
how could you understand it and
many people are coming to understand
whether or not
if it even could be real so could this
actually be real the story sounds so
fantastic could it be real
that there would be a way out of what
seems like the prison of the finite
materialistic
the the spirit is asking for it but the
mind is still in a state of doubt and
fear
and uh it just takes one ceremony where
you have the experience to
understand it so i'll give you an
example early on i had a psychologist
who came down
right so there's a doctor you know
certified
doctor i asked him to put me through
every level of psychological psychiatric
tests he could
uh we did he summed it up that i was not
mentally ill and i was a mystic
so i thought that was awesome so we got
that straight between us
and he finally refused to believe in
spirits right just flatly refused to say
that there was a thing called the spirit
he's like no there's nothing called the
spirit there are archetypes there are
things that the mind creates etc etc so
after his fourth or fifth ceremony i
said okay tell me what happened last
night
he said well a snake came to me and it
talked to me and
uh then i became a
bird and i flew through the forest and
um
you know then these things that kind of
looked like extraterrestrials came and
they talked to me
and then they told me i had something in
me that wasn't healthy for me and so
then i threw it up and i
threw it up into the bucket and um then
these shapes came and they were
emanating voices to me and i was
communicating with them
and he said so i'm willing to admit that
last night i interacted with what you
call a spirit
he said i'm not going to call it a
spirit but i'm willing to admit that i
interacted with what you call a spirit i
said i said that's good enough for me
i said that's all the better i said how
are you feeling he said i feel great i
feel
like the best i've ever felt i said
that's all that mattered like we weren't
here to fight over the idea of it to
begin with
right like who cares what we call it i
love
the experience it's it's so funny how uh
just how different it is the way that
you you're talking about these
experiences and the kind of life that
you live as well you know you're talking
about
being out on the water uh hunting
fishing for your food
for the evening and heading to go and
live off the land so
digging up vegetables and picking
berries and picking leaves and
doing all this sorts of stuff as you're
talking about that and i'm thinking
about it it just
strikes me how different the lives are
that we live
and it's easy to talk about over normal
levels of stimulus through your phone
and
we're eating processed foods and etc etc
but at a much more base level than that
even
if you get rid of the curses of 2020
um the type of lifestyle that we're
living is
so so far removed from yours which must
be more aligned with what we were
typically
supposed to do and then you realize that
you mentioned it earlier on about the
way that language is being used that
has kind of now become weaponized and
you can actually see language advanced
language as a technology
and those are the technologies built on
top of that language which allows us to
further distribute it frictionlessly
across the world and when you think
about that i just wonder
i wonder how much
i wonder how we can balance what is best
for us as a species you know
paleolithically what are we supposed to
be eating
doing how are we supposed to be
communicating what is the level of
information that we're supposed to be
exposed to because it's definitely not
all of the globe's news
in real time 24 hours a day and
everything else i wonder as we get more
and more advanced and
we move towards colonizing ma we're
talking about going to new planets now
what from our ancestry
and our heritage as a species are we
taking with us that's right
and what have we already forgotten
that's wrong
what we're taking that's right is the
the continued evolution of the species
that's what's right evolution doesn't
have a right and wrong about it
evolution just means consistent and
constant change
and i think where we went wrong is
fearing
and being stuck in an experience of
enculturating fear as the means in which
to interact and know each other
so instead of recognizing that we're all
here for
reasons that are really more common than
different we've been taught that there's
more difference than commonality between
us which is just fundamentally false
and so this has created a fear paradigm
that has become enculturated
and it creates a great separation
between what the brain does and what the
heart does
and the heart is an organ that's much
more important than just pumping blood
it is the true
epicentral locus of where you have
your infinite knowledge and connection
to consciousness and the universe itself
which then the brain gets perplexed by
through this idea of language as a
technology
and so what we all we have to do is
bring these two things into balance
and then we ultimately balance
collectively when your heart's open with
somebody else that you know you're not
fighting them
you're not quibbling with them over the
words when you're with somebody you're
just hanging out with them
and what a great thing that is and when
you're holding an infant baby in your
arms you're not saying like
hey why aren't you telling me the right
words or you're not using the right
gender pronoun for me
you're just hanging out with the little
baby like it's not simple and your
heart's totally open and it's like
it's like hey like you're like the
little koala bear they're like hey this
is a koala bear like
you know you're not you're not all
freaked out in your head about things
it's like getting like super neurotic
about that
and so i think that that like
hyper-compulsive neurosis is what is
where we've kind of gone wrong
and we can actually cr collect
collectively correct that as a species
by recognizing that there is a balance
that's here and that it's something that
we can give a little time to
and we can do it together in a way
that's actually fun and
worthwhile and that we can recognize
that that's the bridge to real
consciousness
that the heart has consciousness just
like the brain does and if you've fallen
in love and your brain's going like no
and your heart's going yeah you know it
has consciousness you know you've had
that experience
so you just have to kind of suck it up
right you have to be like well
hey brain you don't get to be fully and
only dominant here there's
also this other part of me that's
equally important and give it some time
to evolve in it
i always say this on our retreats they
put that in the curriculum of school we
would all be different
but you know heart-centered learning
wasn't what was in school it was all
brain-centered learning
and you know shamanic traditions and
spiritual traditions teach a lot of
heart-centered learning
so if you give some time to
heart-centered learning uh
you'll find that it is really fast and
unbelievably evolutionary to you in your
own life
and makes you better at absolutely
everything you do
so it makes you literally better at
absolutely
everything you do so like literally two
three four
five minutes a day to heart centered
learning
it ultimately improves absolutely every
other aspect of your life and so i think
it's like a pretty fair trade
you'll ultimately pick different foods
you'll ultimately start to
realize that certain friends don't
really resonate with you like the way
you thought
and the choices that you make will be
better choices you find that your
fitness
will uh increase and you'll become much
fitter and much healthier
you'll find that the way that you speak
in the way that you think is much more
positive and much more harmonious
you'll find that the relationship sexual
relationship loving relationships you
have are
way better your body will perform better
your sexuality will be better your sex
will be better
you'll find out that your family
relationships will start to improve
you'll become more intelligent literally
you'll you'll grow in
iq points that you never knew would be
possible your left and right right brain
hemispheres will start to balance
themselves
simply from the heart itself which is
like a psychiatric psychological
phenomena
and uh it's something that is actually
really
easy to do it starts in our intention to
recognize the purpose of it
and then there are some basic techniques
to help that along
people that's really like the good or
bad where can people go to find out more
about that they think
that sounds alright i want me a bit of
that hamilton where should they go
well come to our community come to
bluemorphoretreats.world
uh we're on telegram we're at trinity
global
and we have the trinity channel and blue
morpho retreats.world has an
unbelievable number of resources
that are free and some of them like the
trinity live retreat is a three-day
retreat we do where we teach everything
that we're talking about
we use ecstatic breath work if you're in
a place where other kinds of plants are
illegal so you can
perform a completely legal ceremony all
over the world using
uh ecstatic and trans-based breath work
we take you through dieta and teach you
all about the different kinds of
medicinal plants
that can be healthy for you we teach you
the value of intermittent fasting and
how to be able to use all different
kinds of superfoods to be able to
literally
uh supra uh
heal the body with all different kinds
of nutrients and vitamins supersaturate
the body with nutrients and vitamins we
teach you how to build that heart brain
balance
and then we also have a program that's
called sunday enlightenment
which is just a 10 donation which is an
unbelievable thing to get to be a part
of where
we get together on a sunday for a couple
hours it usually goes two to
two to three hours and uh it's also
recorded and people from all over the
world
ask these questions and we go through it
in real time
so as the questions are coming up for
the people in our community we
go through how to how to do this
and how to embrace it and how to
experience it on a
on a daily level and we do it together
in a place of positivity where we foster
growth
we simply believe that each person has
unbelievably unique talents that need to
be unveiled or uncovered
and we do so through these practices
together and
uh then in the community on our telegram
community everyone shares the way that
they're learning
because everyone learns differently and
so no one's right or wrong within the
community we don't fight over ideas we
share
ideas and we support each other and
actually uh you know
being the best human that we can be we
optimize that
and we do it together bluemore for
retreats.world and
telegram community trinity global come
join us it's unbelievably fun
i love it man there's two common threads
that have come up today that i've been
thinking about a lot especially this
year
one of them being that one of the
primary jobs that our senses have
specifically our brain
is not to perceive things but rather to
narrow our field of perception
that it reduces down what we can
perceive
because if we were able to perceive
absolutely everything
firstly we would have so much stimulus
that we wouldn't really be able to move
forward with our day
and secondly we'd probably lose our
minds we're not built to take in that
much information
and one of the things that i'm trying to
do this year is
to reduce down to take those blinkers
off as much as i can to try and live the
experience
of every moment as fully as possible to
feel the wind on my skin to smell the
the smell of the leaves to everything
that i can
from all of the different senses and the
other thing i've been thinking about a
lot is
how head dominant how cerebral we are
when we come and try and find a solution
or an answer for a lot of the things
that are going on
within our own lives within society at
large
and the increasing popularity of
embodiment practices stuff like
yoga and interpretive impressive dance
and meditation and breath work and
you know a guy like wim hof who for
really no reason
should be world famous but is because
people are resonating with the sort of
work that he does in cold therapy and
heat therapy and intermittent fasting
and
plant medicines and all of this sort of
stuff it really does feel
like there is a um swelling underground
movement to try and remind people that
they are an embodied animal that they
are not simply just this
sort of jumble and i i'm aware even from
the most utilitarian rationalist
materialist perspective of anyone that's
listening you cannot tell me
phenomenologically that being in love
just feels like oxytocin
because it doesn't you can't tell me
that dread that getting a message from
someone that you care about saying that
they've been in an accident
just feels like a dump of adrenaline
because it doesn't it feels like
so much more than that and i think that
that really crosses
the bridge that we're talking about here
that no matter what your background is
whether you come into it from a much
more spiritual or a much more i guess
sort of
typical 21st century viewpoint
both people phenomenologically
experience
life the same and there is definitely
a bifurcating in terms of
how how one group of people are trying
to find this solution
and increasingly i think that that black
hole is
starting to suck more and more and more
people in uh and of the ones who are
doing it of the ones who are
taking more time within body practices
and listening to themselves in
in ways that are less cerebral um i know
very few of them and in fact i know none
of them who have done it and regretted
it
so i think the um the work that you guys
are doing is really really important i'm
very glad that you're continuing
i really appreciate that you know i
completely agree with you
when you are saying that what comes to
my mind is the elephants
we all understand the elephants as
mammals and they all care about their
ancestors and they remember and go
hundreds of miles to go to the places
where different elephants have passed on
where they died
where now there's literally no traces of
the elephant body anymore
there on the land at all and they'll go
back and visit that site and they will
mourn the grave of that animal
and so how are we any different
literally how are we any different than
that and so i think people have
forgotten
by making a materialist view something
that's not miraculous
but there's no explanation for the
universe itself so you can have an
entirely materialistic view
and that's still a miracle because where
did the matter come from
just ask yourself that like where did
you get all of these stars in galaxies
and then
where'd you get a body and where'd you
get eyes and you can say evolution and
you can say yeah a billion years of that
and then you can go back five billion
years and earth is a cloud
of stardust and you can go back 12
billion years and you can see the
formation of the matter
that made up this universe itself you
can go back 13 billion years
plus and then you're going to find an
event horizon where you're not going to
be able to tell time anymore
and at that point at that origin you're
going to have to ask yourself where did
all this stuff come from
and that's the end of the materialistic
view and it still doesn't have an origin
story that anyone can agree on
i don't think it ultimately matters
that's that's really interesting that
actually even the most materialistic
viewpoint in the world
reaches a boundary and the boundary that
you you just identified there is
temporal
right that there is a time limit that we
can get to
with that so time being one of the most
fundamental uh forces the fourth
dimension
that moves us allows us to move through
this existence the way that we do
someone who concedes that that
does exist that that is a particular
limit to the utilitarian materialistic
worldview
and yet discounts the
spiritual the astral the cosmic
the energetic answers and and potential
solutions
to things does feel a little bit like
there's a discontinuity
in their type of thinking how can you
concede it on one hand and yet argue on
the other
that's me i there will be a lot of
people who in the comments below do
decide to argue it
but my point is that there's something
going on there
and the the fact that we don't have a
single answer for everything yet
means that the open loops that we've got
um
they they permit us to to find different
answers to these questions
i completely agree and it's a place for
consciousness to continue to be explored
i think what we haven't explored yet
enough is consciousness
so i would like the people who believe
only in materialism to be able to
describe to me
the boundaries and the dimensionalities
of consciousness
and to do so in a codified way that
fully explains the origin of
consciousness
the totality of consciousness uh the
reach of consciousness
and the evolution of consciousness and
if we can do that together
i think then we would understand a
common language without there being a
disagreement
and um i think people have been fighting
over the words about consciousness for
way too long utilizing consciousness
itself
which is still the greatest mystery of
all i love it man
thank you so much everything will be
linked in the show notes below including
blue morpho retreat
anything else any other stuff that
people should check out
no blue morpho retreats.world check us
out uh
through our community and through our
social we talk about all the other
projects that we're doing
we're involved in a number of other
projects that are
not so much based specifically in
spirituality but about helping the world
in different ways we're interested
in blockchain technology and all
different
kinds of uh crypto based technologies
we're interested in what the future of
the planet is ultimately going to look
like we're interested in green energy
and permaculture
and the transformation of uh
the land and the earth as a way of being
able to sustain humanity for literally
tens of thousands of generations to come
and so if you're interested
in not only the past and interested in
spirituality or interested
in you know your own optimization
there's also all of this other amazing
uh space that we also cover and so just
through our community itself we share
and discuss all of these ideas come join
us
beautiful man thank you so much for your
time today i've really really enjoyed it
and hopefully at some point in the
future when the world reopens i may
i may be able to come and see where you
are that'd be fantastic it'd be a
pleasure thank you guys so much for
having me on the show
it's an unbelievable pleasure thank you
[Music]